Jews Muslims and Christians the three
abrahamic faiths all believe in the
religious importance of Jerusalem which
is why the city has been fought over
many times over many centuries with one
site a particular Flashpoint for
violence
[Music]
Haram al-sharif which translates as the
noble sanctuary in English is in the
Southeast corner of Jerusalem's Old City
the compound is home to two significant
mosques Al-Aqsa and the golden topped
Dome of the Rock
Muslims believe that the prophet
Muhammad made his night Journey from
Mecca to Jerusalem and then Rose to
Heaven from here which is why after the
cities of Mecca and Medina Al-Aqsa is
the third most holy site in the Islamic
faith
[Music]
to Jews the site is known as the Temple
Mount they believe it is where King
Solomon built the first temple around
3000 years ago the temple was destroyed
by the Babylonians but it Remains the
most holy site in the Jewish faith
the Western Wall is the only remaining
supporting wall of the original Temple
and the external area is the only place
on the site where Jews can pray
Israel captured Jerusalem's Old City
including Al-Aqsa compound in the 1967
Six-Day War
it was then agreed that Jordan would
remain the custodian of the Holy site
and a trust called the wakov was
appointed to oversee it there is an
agreement known as the status quo that
allows Jews and other religions to visit
Al-Aqsa Moss compound at certain
controlled times of the day they are
expressly forbidden from praying there
in reality though Israeli police control
Security in Jerusalem giving them
considerable power over who can and
can't enter Al-Aqsa they often storm the
compound which results in violent
confrontations with Palestinian
worshipers
for Palestinians living in the West Bank
access to Alexa compound can be
difficult for Palestinians living in
Gaza it can be almost impossible
but some Jews try and openly pray in the
grounds of the compound in defiance of
the rules and Israeli police are often
accused of turning a blind eye to this
some Jewish activist movements want to
retake the compound and build a new
synagogue there some of those
individuals are now ministers in the
current Israeli government
This concerns Palestinians and Arab
nations in the Middle East who believe
that Israel is slowly trying to retake
the site and that is why it is often a
Flashpoint for violence in 2000 a visit
by Ariel Sharon the then opposition
leader in Israel triggered a violent
reaction from Palestinians and led to a
second major Uprising known as an
interfada and in 2021 clashes at the
site led to a 10-day war with Hamas the
militant Group which controls the Gaza
Strip
[Music]
nearly a few hundred meters from Al-Aqsa
and the Western Wall is the Church of
the Holy Sepulcher where Jesus was said
to have been nailed to the cross and
later rose from the dead
Christians who are now a tiny minority
in Jerusalem have suffered increasing
attacks in recent years
religion and religious beliefs run
through the battles and tensions that
shape the city today there is perhaps
nowhere else in the world where the past
has such an influence on the present and
the future